خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه هجم طيارون
انتحاريون يابانيون سفن الحلفاء بطائراتهم
التي انفجرت بعدما اصابت اهدافها بدقه
فكان مصيرهم الموت
وبعد 80 عاما طائره الكاميكازي الانتحاريه
تعود للواجهه
ليله ساخنه في سماء موسكو وكيف تبادل
الطرفان فيها القصف عبر طائرات الانتحاريه
طائرات الكاميكازي ولكن بلا طيار لها فعل
الصواريخ الباليسيه ولكن مع فرق فهي سهله
التصنيع رخيصه الثمن تطلق يدويا بمنصات
بسيطه يمكن تغيير اهدافها بعد الاطلاق
يصعب كشفها تتمتع بقدره تدميريه كبيره
وتصيب اهدافها بدقه تمتلك الولايات
المتحده انواعا منها ابرزها الكاميكازي
اسرائيل طورت اسرابا منها تقطع 100
الكيلومترات وقدرتها التدميريه كبيره
تركيا باعت منها العشرات وايران قدمت
لروسيا طائرات شاهد التي لا تتجاوز قيمه
الواحده منها عشرين الف دولار
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه تمكنت ايضا
بامكانيه بسيطه من تصنيع اعداد من هذه
الطائرات كما برز مؤخرا استخدامها من قبل
عصابات اجراميه لتنفيذ عمليات قتل وتفجير
برمجه اهداف الطائرات الانتحاريه تتم
مسبقا عبر انظمه تحديد المواقع او التحكم
بها عن بعد بواسطه انظمه الاتصالات
والكاميرات المثبته عليها ما يجعل منها
سلاحا فتاكا سيغير من شكل الحروب الحديثه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات